hans-gerd maßen ist der ehemalige chef
des bundesverfassungsschutzes und unter
sehr dramatischen umständen aus dem amt
gekommen sie haben hier wahlkampf
gemacht in dresden für die cdu genau
gesagt für die werte union aber am ende
hat der ministerpräsident kretschmann
gesagt auf die unterstützung verzichten
wir lieber wie gehen sie damit um
ich kann damit umgehen ich finde es
schade von so kontraproduktiv
ich fand es sehr gut dass die werte
union nach der europaparlamentswahl die
an desaster für die cdu gerade in
sachsen war gesagt hatte wir müssen uns
an bringen wir fragen lassen ob er sich
da nicht auch einbringen will
und wenn ich vergleiche wie die
meinungsumfragen im juli waren für die
cdu der lack die cdu kopf an kopf mit
der afg und heute bei über 30 prozent
dann sage ich das rechne ich auch der
werte union und ein stück weit auch mir
zu der ministerpräsident kretschmann
wird wahrscheinlich sagen diesen erfolg
haben wir dem zu verdanken dass ich mich
klar und eindeutig abgegrenzt habe gegen
die afg hatte da recht mit diesem kurs
das halte ich nicht für zu treffen weil
ansonsten werden die umfragen auch die
europa parlamentswahl im mai anders
ausgegangen weil er sich vorher auch
nicht viel anders geäußert hat als
danach
und ich glaube auch dass die
bratwürstchen braterei und das
händeschütteln auch nicht dazu geführt
hat dass in meinungsumfragen der
ministerpräsident kandidat zu stark
gestiegen ist
trotzdem normal den nachfrage halten sie
es für richtig dass sich die cdu klar
und eindeutig von der afg abgrenzt
oder können sie sich eine zusammenarbeit
vorstellen
ich habe wiederholt gesagt ich kann mir
keine koalition mit der fdp vorstellen
genauso wenig allerdings auch wie eine
koalition mit den linken und den grünen
die ich auch für ausgesprochen
problematisch halte wie wir das ergebnis
hier in sachsen jetzt in realpolitik
umwandeln werden muss selbst der
ministerpräsident kandidat sehen
beziehungsweise die cdu hier vor ort das
ist ein schwieriges ergebnis
ich würde mir wünschen man könnte es
fast 6 mit der spd an
machen sie sich als ehemalige chef des
verfassungsschutzes sorgen um unsere
demokratie wenn hier in sachsen und
brandenburg die afg so stark abschneiden
ich mache mir sorgen weil ich sehe dass
wir jetzt hier in sachsen und in
brandenburg die zehnte und elfte wahl
haben wo die cdu nach 2016 er verloren
hat teilweise dramatisch sogar verloren
hat und wo ich den eindruck habe dass
viele parteifunktionäre sich gerne im
20er oder 30er spektrum des
parteienspektrums wohlfühlen hauptsache
wir haben irgendwie die mehrheit vor der
afg so kann es nicht sein dass es keine
volkspartei mehr
was ist denn ihr rezept soll die cdu
nach rechts rücken oder wie stellen sie
sich das vor
ich stelle mir vor dass die cdu wie
früher auch als volkspartei versucht
alle flügel abzudecken von den sozialen
christsozialen den evangelischen
katholiken den arbeitnehmern den
handwerkern und arbeitgebern bis eben
auch zu den konservativen
das hat die cdu in teilen verloren wie
es auch die spd verloren hat und die
bilanz der spd ist negativ und die
bilanz der cdu ist jedenfalls seit 2016
auch deutlich negativ das muss geändert
werden
aus meiner sicht geht es nicht mit einem
weiter so dass man sagt wir machen
einfach so weiter und bei der nächsten
landtagswahl hier in dresden dann landen
wir bei 21 prozent
hauptsache vielleicht ein prozent vor
der afg so kann es nicht gehen
manch einer wirft ihnen vor sie würden
selbst mit der ard liebäugeln mit ihren
positionen werden sie bei der afg
vielleicht sogar besser aufgehoben als
bei der cdu
das ist völliger unsinn wenn immer die
programmatik der cdu der letzten zehn
jahre oder einige reden der
bundeskanzlerin noch von 2010 oder 2011
vergleich der wird dermaßen tour und die
werte union sehen wenn ich
zufälligerweise positionen vertrete die
auch von der afg vertreten werden und
das längst nicht auf die position die
wahren verfassungsschutzpräsident was
streben sie denn jetzt an werden sie
gern eine karriere in der cdu machen
können sie sich vorstellen als minister
in eine landesregierung als
innenminister einzutreten
ich bin zunächst einmal rechtsanwalt und
bin beratend tätig und bin damit
eigentlich auch ganz zufrieden zufrieden
was ich möchte ist eine politikwende in
der cdu ich möchte veränderungen
bestimmten politikbereich noch das
migrations und sicherheitspolitik ist
oder die energiepolitik die ich
überhaupt nicht für realistisch halte
das strebe ich an wenn das mit dem
jetzigen politischen personal geht es
gut ich habe nur die befürchtung dem
jetzigen politischen personal werden wir
diese politikwende nicht schaffen und
dann müssen wir uns anderes politisches
personal anschaffen noch ein kurzer
rückblick auf ihr ende als präsident des
verfassungsschutz welchen fehler haben
sie gemacht warum musste das so es ist
kein fehler die wahrheit zu sagen und
ich muss sagen ich bin letztendlich froh
dass ich nach sechs jahren drei monaten
15 tagen nicht mehr 24 stunden sieben
tage die woche bereitschaft habe